you probably finished your first
playthrough with one of the weapons that
you found in the early game the sauce
spear the axe the cane these are good
weapons but if you're starting a new
character why not start the game with
the blades of mercy the right upper lash
or the ligarius wheel and contrary to
popular belief you can get these weapons
fairly early it might surprise you to
hear this but about 80% of the weapons
can be found within a couple of hours of
starting the game we're gonna track down
these weapons fastest first the first
thing I wanted to get on this character
was the blades of mercy which is a short
sword that snaps off into two small
taggers for these we need the crow
hunter's badge and for that we need to
kill Eileen as long as you haven't
killed Gascoigne Eileen can be found
near the rafters above the sewers and
it's exactly these rafters that allow us
to kill her this early in the game so
you start the encounter by doing as much
damage as you can before she outgrows
onto you charge nartu and let her
recover and then wait a moment because
she's still not aggro'd charge another
and this time perform a visceral attack
so now she's hostile and she's low
enough on health to die from gravity
well I get back to the rafters and go
straight across but then you want to
stand on the first rafter off to the
left but don't go too far along and as
you wait here my lane should fall off in
the gap between the two rafters
regardless of how you do it it is
important to get her to fall in the
small channel in the middle otherwise
she'll survive the fall and if she does
survive the fall then Molotov cocktails
are your best friend for killing her at
this point now that you have the crow
hunter badge you'll be able to buy the
blades of mercy and the crow feather set
from the messengers in the dream be
warned though by killing her here you
miss out on her quest line which allows
you to pick up a couple of gestures two
runes and the hunter of hunters covenant
if you want to get the blades without
killing her then you'll have to follow
her quest line all the way until rom the
vacuous spider so this is a much faster
way of doing it back up on top of the
rafters is a chain that suspends the
sauce spear an alternate version of the
song cleaver you can pick this up here
or you can buy it along with all the
other starting weapons once you get this
saw hunters badge the saw hunters badge
is further along
in the sewers behind the giant pig in
the tunnel next the Kirkham which is an
awesome strength weapon that's a sword
and great hammer and the repeating
pistol which shoots two bullets at once
simply killed the cleric based to unlock
these at the messengers bath next up is
the flame sprayer a flamethrower weapon
that consumes Quicksilver bullets make
sure you talk to Gilbert at this window
by the central yharnam lantern and then
after you kill Gascoigne go back to
Gilbert and he'll give it to you it's as
simple as that now we move into old yarn
as soon as you encounter this sauce beer
hunter you look back at the building you
just dropped off and then to the left of
that building there's a little drop-down
area go inside the building go up the
stairs and behind the cabinet is a rifle
spear a spear slash halberd hybrid with
a shotgun built into the l2 of the
halberd also in old yharnam is the
hunter's torch as soon as you walk out
from the lantern drop off this ledge and
run around the building to the left
the hunters torch boasts way more damage
and way better scaling than the regular
torch you find in central yharnam it's
actually a fairly good weapon especially
against beasts because they're weak to
fire and while we're in the old yharnam
let's kill dura at the top of the tower
for the powder keg badge now the powder
keg badge unlocks the stake driver and
the rifle spear for purchase as soon as
you get atop his tower just shoot him
four times with a pistol to knock him
off or dash forward and blast him once
or twice with your shotgun reload your
game and the badge will be sitting atop
the tower for you at the end of all the
Arnim is the blood starved beast and if
you kill it then it'll unlock a bunch of
new paths which hide three new weapons
so once it's dead walk to cathedral ward
and you'll note as this door off to the
right has opened head inside and then
ascends the church workshop to discover
the radiant sword hunter's badge at the
top this unlocks Ludwig's holy blade a
great sword that snaps off into a
longsword and Ludwig's rifle which is a
shotgun and also the flame sprayer in
case you didn't get it earlier and now
guys we get into the really good stuff
the stuff you might have missed in your
playthrough so after the blood starved
beast is dead
snatches will appear throughout the
world there these big dudes carrying a
sack and if you die to one
you'll get dragged off to the hype
in jail one snatcher that's easy to get
to is the one below the church workshop
to get to this snatcher so you can die
to it you go right from the Cathedral
Ward lamp you approach the workshop you
go around to the right of the workshop
and you drop down and then you continue
dropping down all the way to the bottom
and then you run through the village
until you find a snatcher
so just die to it on purpose here and
you'll awaken in the hypogeum jail and
once you've awakened head up the
rotating staircase and make sure you hit
that lamp if you're still listening to
this long description you just run
through the hall until you get outside
and then you turn left and you run down
the street that's filled with the dogs
don't bother to kill anything it's a
hassle so just run to the very end and
guarded by another snatcher and two dogs
is the tinnitus which is a one-handed
lightning mace pressing l2 on this
weapon doesn't change its form but it
does imbue it with a lightning effect
for a short time alternatively you can
get the tonight recycling pile who's at
the bottom of the jail but he's quite a
difficult boss at this stage of the game
after you've killed Amelia and triggered
the cutscenes the world state changes
and a couple of NPCs will move and if
you've talked to Alfred before then
you'll now find him here off to the side
of the church courtyard and just above
that password guy that takes you to the
next area now that he's in his second
location he actually drops the wheel
hunter badge upon death which means
we're going to kill him
because this unlocks the weapon ligarius
wheel for purchase he's incredibly tough
to kill if you try and kill him legit
so let's cheese him a little for this
you'll want at least twenty Quicksilver
bullets a blunderbuss and a hunter's axe
we're going to get him in an endless
visceral attack cycle so first put your
Hunter's axe in its shortened form and
charge in r2 we're going to try and hit
him so he gets stuck in between the
coffin and the wall and he actually
starts in the perfect location for this
so once you have him here he should be
hostile start madly shooting at him and
the chances are very very high that
you'll parry one of his attacks as long
as you using the blunderbuss so visceral
attack and then once he's on the ground
you immediately charge your
to to bring him standing upright again
and as soon as he's standing upright you
start mashing l2 to shoot again your
second shot will always be timed
perfectly
with this method so visceral attack you
charge the r2 you shoot him twice
you visceral attack you charge the r2
you shoot him twice and just repeat that
ad nauseam it's as simple as that
if you do mess this up then you can just
try and parry him into a corner and
you'll be able to replicate this
perfectly the ligarius wheel is quickly
becoming one of my favourite weapons and
the next item is the ROS marinus it's
similar to the flame sprayer except it
sprays this grey mist instead if you get
enough build-up on an enemy it inflicts
this stacking effects that's somewhat
similar to the poison effect I'm not
exactly sure how it works actually
though I believe it works very well with
an arcane build you'll need the cosmic I
watch a badge to unlock this weapon and
you'll have to progress all the way to
ROM before it's even possible to get
this once rom is dead the path - yah-ha
goal is open in yaja goo you'll need to
find the upper cathedral ward key
remember this courtyard with the
amygdala that shoots lasers at you while
there's a gap in the right side of the
fence which you should drop down to
explore within drop down a few times and
you'll eventually find the upper
cathedral Ward key so you take this key
back to Cathedral Ward and you go all
the way up the Church workshop until you
come to this locked door then you
progress far within and just keep
exploring and killing enemies until you
inevitably come to this big dark open
area in a hallway to the right of the
main staircase leading down you'll find
the cosmic I watch a badge which unlocks
the Rose marinus poison knives blue
Alex's sedatives and twin bloodstone
shards now let's talk about the weapons
you can get by doing a little skip at
the start of the game to be honest I do
this skip on every one of my characters
now because I love the knight set and I
really like the rapier you find in
cainhurst castle so I'm really keen to
share it with you I hope they don't
patch it but they might but anyway to do
it you walked the central yharnam lamp
and then you go down until you
is that dead end with the executioner
make sure you unlock this gate because
we might have to use it to get a quick
run back if you mess this up and then go
and kill the executioner then you face
this coffin on the ground at this exact
angle and attempt to jump just as soon
as your foot touches the coffin after a
few tries maybe 10 or 20 tries you'll
glitch up here onto this wall run along
it to the right until you approach the
sacks then step onto the sacks turn
around and face the fence in an angle
that you see here we're going to do a
charge attack with the saw cleaver and
it will propel us just far enough that
we clip through the fence and land on
the opposite side of the fence if you do
mess this up then run through the gate
we just unlocked and try again because
we do want to land on the other side of
the fence run along the fence once you
successfully do this and then drop down
on the other side and now you're behind
you're safe cos Clinic way earlier than
you're supposed to be and there are two
different paths from here the ladder
down leads to the Forbidden Forest and
the cannon weapon and going up to yosef
cos clinic will allow you to get the
cainhurst summons which allows you to
get to cainhurst castle much faster and
cainhurst castle holds the writer Palash
the evelyn the knight set and the
chikage let's get those items first once
you have this summons you can speedrun'
your way to the grand Cathedral and then
you turn left onto hem which charnel
Lane at the end make sure you kill the
witches of hem wick and then you double
back and stand at this pillar to
activate the cainhurst travel cutscene
as soon as you arrive in cainhurst the
writer flash is waiting for you in the
main hall in a chest off to the right
the writer Palash which i've been
pronouncing differently every time i say
it is a rapier that transforms into a
shorter rapier and gun progress further
into the castle until you reach the room
with the elevator on the right side of
the room is a short staircase run up it
and jump to get inside this group of
tables that hides a chest inside is the
evelyn a stylish high blood tinged
scaling pistol continue up the main
staircase to reach level 2 on level 2
you'll spot a broken window on the other
side drop down carefully to the paved
area below and then go inside the first
door you see you're now on the other
side of level
in one of the chests in this room is the
night set which isn't a weapon but it's
awesome
and if you progress further outside
you'll eventually pull the lever that
opens up the path to the boss of cane
host Castle motto ligarius is a tough
fight for an early character but if you
do beat him then you can put on his
crown and unlock the next area and the
next weapon talk to the Queen get her
badge by joining covenant and you'll be
able to purchase the chikage from the
messengers if you want the cannon you'll
have to go to the Forbidden Forest go
down this ladder
immediately after the skip we did before
and then go through a swamp like area
and you'll end up in the Forbidden
Forest around the dog cages find the
short flammable swamp nearby run through
and then run towards the next stretch
where someone fires a cannon at you and
you'll eventually arrive at this dark
watchtower you just get up on the
balcony you go up a ladder and drop off
the rafters until you find this item
which is the cannon it requires 30
strength consumes 10 Quicksilver bullets
per shot but Tam does this thing pack a
punch it's pretty much a must-have for a
strength build I'd say next up Arthur
beast claws the only weapon that's found
exclusively within the chalice dungeons
to start you'll have to have killed
Amelia and then you'll need to get the
tonsil stone from one of the many
windows you can find patches in get
grabbed by the invisible amigdala
to the right of the grand Cathedral and
then progressed through the lecture hall
and nightmare frontier and then kill
amigdala amygdala drops the ailing Laura
and chalice to activate the ailing laron
chalice you'll need 9 level for ritual
blood which is found within depth 3 and
depth for chalice dungeons to put it
simply just progress as far as you can
through the two marrow chalice dungeon
which you should have unlocked by
killing the blood starved beast and in
central to marrow you'll find the hinted
tomb chalice which in turn leads to the
unlocking of the lower hinted tomb
chalice
I ran lower hinted tomb a couple of
times until I had 9 level for ritual
blood then I also bought for cold blood
flower buds from the inside messengers
to unlock the ailing Loran chow
god it's almost as boring explaining
this as it actually was to farm all
those materials but anyway once you've
unlocked the ailing Loran chalice simply
progressed until you've defeated the
first boss of the first layer go down
one elevator after this and then
immediately turned to the side passage
in the hallway before you touch the
second lantern at the end of this side
passage is a treasure room that contains
the beasts claw the beasts claw is a
one-handed claw weapon that transforms
your other hand into a beast like state
and the one weapon I wish you could get
earlier is the burial blade the curved
sword that snaps into a scythe it's
available for purchase after you kill
gurmann killing gurmann immediately
takes you to new game+ but there is a
way to avoid this first gather the third
umbilical cords and consume three before
you kill gurmann once the Blood Moon is
triggered from killing rom you get one
from killing yourself go one from
killing Ariana's baby one from the old
hunters workshop and another from
Margo's wet-nurse if you consume three
before killing German it triggers
another fight after gurmann so consume
the cords kill German and make sure you
die to the moon presents boss that
follows this will take you to the
hunters dream and it will leave all of
your shortcuts intact and basically
allows you to stay in your game with the
burial blade without going to New Game+
so I hope you enjoy this sorry about my
voice in this video I'm really quite
sick at the moment but leave a like if
you enjoyed it hopefully this helps you
build the character you want to build as
soon as possible and I also recommend
going to the Extra Life wiki especially
if you're trying to find based clause in
the chalice dungeon because the write-up
the Extra Life wiki has on the chalice
dungeons is really good and should
really help you there but other than
that thanks for watching guys and I'll
see you in the next one
[Music]